[Music]
my question is then where is the
opposition coming from who are the
lobbyists that are saying uh no no no
this hurts our business because clearly
there must be big money on the other
side and intuitively i don't know right
away who that would be you know so a lot
of it i think is inertia cone and it's
like you've got this billions of dollars
of our taxes going every year like nine
billion dollars for just domestic
enforcement unenforceable drug laws and
a lot of jobs are dependent on it you've
got private prison industries um
and you've got pharmaceutical companies
that might be threatened by a less
expensive pain alternative
so i think really pharmaceutical
companies don't want people smoking pot
they want them like no aleve or whatever
is better you know we i shouldn't
mention an actual product i'm sure
it might be a sponsor
um
but let's just say there were a pill
like a leave
you have companies pharmaceutical
companies that say no no we we we really
don't want anyone smoking pot because we
want to be able to sell them a pill that
gives them the same
well first of all i can't believe we've
gotten this far into the segment without
this like studio exploding that we're
being allowed to talk about this on
national television i think might be a
sign that the americas is ready for the
drug war to be is america ready for the
drug war to be over
again
[Music]
that was more than four people again
these people are very biased
do you ever feel like legalizing uh pot
cannabis whatever would be easier
if the the strains of of marijuana had
more sensible names do you know what i
mean i really do i really do think like
there's stuff like you know blueberry
yum yum you know and
you know strange cloud bob you know
there's there's
and you think well that's maybe making
it too comical you know what i'm saying
should we come up with more serious
names for kinds and strains of marijuana
i agree with you 100 because i actually
in researching this book i did see a lot
of people that were genuinely helped i
mean lives extended cancer patients that
got their appetite back and so it it
demands
um a little bit of a maturation of the
industry you know people that you know
need to pull up their pants over their
butts and straighten their hats out and
make the presentation to the american
medical association it's going to be
like a difficult case to say that this
tumor-reducing sativa intake blend is
comes from a satan's parent um you know
blended with a green crack you know
mother that's that's got to change
you're out of here man
thanks for having me
i want an immediate urine test from you
i'm just the message
you're just the messenger man they don't
call the green room for nothing
[Laughter]
i'm curious just this is my own question
but are there places you know the way
wine growers have those perfect places
in the country to grow wine where the
soil and the climate is just is that
true of of marijuana as well are there
certain places where a real purist is
like oh you really want to get up there
to the hills of oregon
and the mist comes in and it's just the
perfect place well i think um there is
some truth humans have actually been
using this plant for thousands of years
and so um it's evolved and adapted to to
work in a lot of climates but what was
so nice about um the emerald triangles
they call it up there in northern
california as for cannabis was really
the cultural climate as much as anything
else where
people are they want to brand it like
napa did with wine they want to have uh
what do they call it like
wake and bake bed and breakfasts you
know something like that where people
can come in so it's the same idea of
like you you you go from different
vineyard to vineyard
you go from different farm to farm and
you try what they have there and then
you have a little cheese
a little cheese
dorito you know
our artisanal doritos an artisanal
burrito for
you that's good and then you're driven
by a responsible hippie to the next
[Laughter]
cheech or chong takes you to the next
location
i mean would you sign up for that
you know i'm not the right guy to ask
you know i'm too uptight and kooky um
but yeah i definitely would i'd be there
i'd want to try it you know
i'm a believer in trying things sure
andy you'd come with me we'd get
oh man andy would lead the way
we're gonna bring the reverend balls
with
we're gonna us gonna get a vw bus
the four of us are gonna drive up there
come on
come on reverend put on your elephant
thong let's go